y
[Música]
en el noveno día de invasión a ucrania
las tropas rusas continúan su avance por
el sur del país y se dirigen hacia la
ciudad de mikolaj para sólo 100 km de
odessa un puerto clave en el mar negro
en el noreste los militares siguen
presionando para tomar el control de
arco la segunda ciudad del país donde
han intensificado los bombardeos
ante el consejo de seguridad de naciones
unidas reunido de emergencia el director
general del organismo internacional de
energía atómica rafael grossi alertó que
no puede haber normalidad sin militares
controlan una central nuclear esto luego
de que el ejército ruso bombardear a y
tomar el control de la planta de sap
orilla rusia aseguró que el ataque fue
iniciado por saboteadores ucranianos
para acusar a moscú
ya son más de 1.2 millones los
refugiados que han tenido que huir de
ucrania en medio del conflicto y otro
millón el que se ha desplazado
internamente por la guerra la acnur
alertó que la situación empeorará con
los ataques a grandes ciudades del país
buenas noches para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
fue valentina torres sánchez damos
inicio en ucrania donde las tropas rusas
continúan avanzando en el noveno día de
invasión los bombardeos siguen sobre que
al tiempo que el convoy militar que está
a las afueras de la capital retomó su
camino entretanto el instituto para el
estudio de la guerra informó que en el
sur las tropas rusas continúan su avance
por gerson ciudad que ya controlan y
ahora se dirigen hacia mykolaiv un
territorio que se encuentra a sólo 100
kilómetros de odessa un importante
puerto en el mar negro por el noreste
los bombardeos se intensificaron en la
ciudad de járkov justamente en este
contexto el presidente volodymyr
selenski criticó que la otan se negara a
establecer una zona de exclusión aérea
y rousset que creen nada todos los
servicios de inteligencia de la otan
conocen bien los planes del enemigo
también han confirmado que rusia quiere
continuar la ofensiva como es posible
llevamos nueve días asistiendo a una
guerra feroz están destruyendo nuestras
ciudades están bombardeando a nuestra
gente sabiendo que son inevitables
nuevos ataques y nuevas víctimas la otan
ha decidido deliberadamente no cerrar
los cielos de ucrania escrivá tenemos la
doctrina el consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas se reunió de emergencia
este viernes luego de que en la
madrugada las tropas rusas bombardearon
la central nuclear de sabor' y allá la
más grande de su tipo en europa en el
encuentro participó vía remota el
director general del organismo
internacional de energía atómica rafael
grossi quien explicó que los sistemas de
seguridad de la central no se vieron
comprometidos cerca de los reactores
desde nueva york a mensah la
corresponsal de france 24 nos amplió más
temprano
si ha sido una reunión de emergencia del
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
a petición del reino unido- y apoyada
por otros países como francia y eeuu
para tratar las consecuencias del ataque
a la central nuclear
en ucrania ha participado también en
esta reunión el director general de la
agencia internacional de energía atómica
mariano gross y quien ha dicho que
afortunadamente ninguno de los seis
reactores que allí se encuentra ha sido
dañado porque el proyectil ha caído en
otro edificio donde no estaban estos
reactores ya he dicho que de momento no
ha habido ninguna fuga de material
radioactivo el mismo se ha ofrecido a
viajar a ucrania para inspeccionar las
nucleares y asegurarse de que no hay
peligro ha dicho que desde luego la
normalidad no va a volver hasta esa
teniendo en cuenta que esa casa central
está ahora mismo controlada por fuerzas
militares
occidente ha denunciado este ataque ha
dicho que es irresponsable e ilegal la
embajadora del reino unido ha ido más
allá ha recordado las palabras del
presidente vladimir putin de ayer
diciendo que todo estaba yendo según lo
ocurrido ella le dice usted sabe todos
los que estamos en esta mesa sabemos que
eso no es así que ha subestimado al
mundo que ha subestimado la respuesta de
occidente la representante de eeuu ha
vuelto a pedir unanimidad para pedir a
rusia para exigir a rusia que frene
estos ataques que son tan peligrosos ha
dicho que el mundo entero ha contenido
la respiración mientras veíamos este
ataque a esa central nuclear en tiempo
real y esto no puede no puede volver a
ocurrir de hecho le pedí a rusia que se
comprometiera en esa mesa de la reunión
del consejo de seguridad a prometer que
no iba a volver a ocurrir rusia sigue
negando que ellos han sido los culpables
dice que esto han sido saboteadores
ucranianos y que toda esta situación no
forma parte más que de una campaña de
desinformación en contra de rusia el
representante de ucrania le dice que se
deje de mentiras que él sabe
perfectamente lo que está pasando en su
país y que la pasada noche podía haber
sido la última noche de ucrania y del
resto de europa
este viernes la onu informó que la
invasión rusa ucrania ha desatado un
éxodo de más de 1.2 millones de personas
en tan solo 9 días de ofensiva rusa de
seguir así la onu advierte que la guerra
en ucrania puede provocar que hasta 10
millones de personas dejen el país juan
pabló lucumí tiene más detalles
un éxodo inédito en europa en décadas en
promedio unas 134.000 personas han huido
de ucrania cada 24 horas los países
fronterizos como rumanía y polonia son
los principales receptores de aquellos
que escapan del país bajo ataque según
el presidente polaco su país ha recibido
al menos un 60 por ciento de todos los
refugiados aseguro que proceden de más
de 170 países y que todos son
bienvenidos y recibirán el mismo nivel
de ayuda sin importar su procedencia
por supuesto el conflicto en ucrania es
una agresión rusa porque es la verdad
somos miembros de la otan y de la unión
europea y cooperamos con nuestros
aliados uno de los que salió fue uruguay
un estudiante sirio de 24 años que
residía en jarkko cuando rusia lanzó su
guerra contra ucrania esta es la tercera
vez que debe dejar sus planes y sus
sueños una situación que para él se
repite
cada vez que me acostumbro a un lugar
conozco más a mis amigos y luego lo dejo
todo y me voy es tan duro y
decepcionante para mí y lo odio pero qué
puedo hacer es la guerra donde quiera
que esté líbano tuvo una crisis
económica y también tuve que huir del
país así como ahora también de ucrania
me recuerda mucho a siria
como uruguay muchos en su vida llevan
tan solo lo que consideran necesario se
quedan sin comida y sin agua o deben
dormir en la calle episodios que
seguirán repitiéndose a causa de la
guerra esta semana la o no aseguró que
el conflicto bélico en ucrania puede
provocar que hasta 10 millones de
personas tengan que dejar sus hogares lo
que significaría que cerca del 25 por
ciento de la población ucraniana dejaría
el país
praga lisboa frankfurt belgrado beijing
e incluso una fábrica de banderas en
cincinnati todos se han convertido en
escenarios para mostrar apoyo a ucrania
o rusia en medio del conflicto en el
siguiente informe de omar esa recorremos
la vía de las voces solidarias con uno u
otro bando
los ucranianos merecen todo nuestro
apoyo porque ellos se están peleando por
nosotros si ellos no lo detienen
tendremos que hacerlo nosotros en unos
años
la voz de este estudiante reunido junto
a varios centenares de personas para
manifestar su apoyo a ucrania es la de
muchos europeos que salen a las calles
es la semana pasada para rechazar la
invasión rusa en frankfurt alemania una
multitud se congregó para escuchar el
mensaje del presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski en una transmisión
por zoom lo mismo sucedió en tíflis
georgia un país que ya sufrió una
invasión rusa hace 14 años
y la solidaridad hacia la causa
ucraniana incluso ha dado un impulso a
esta fábrica en el suroeste de ohio
abrumada por pedidos de banderas de ese
país
qué bien
y llegué el lunes y tenía algunos
correos de diferentes vendedores del
país tomaban un poco más de un centenar
y para el martes o miércoles hasta hoy
totalizamos más de 500 banderas en este
momento
en lisboa las manifestaciones en apoyo a
ucrania se apostaron frente a las
embajadas con un asiento en el consejo
de seguridad de la onu y en bruselas lo
hicieron frente a la sede de la otan
para apoyar el reclamo ucraniano de una
zona de exclusión aérea incluso en china
los atletas ucranianos se reunieron poco
antes de la inauguración de los juegos
paralímpicos de invierno de beijing para
pedir el fin de la invasión y recibieron
el respaldo de sus compañeros de otros
países pero en europa no hay unanimidad
en serbia un país que mantiene lazos
políticos étnicos y hasta religiosos con
rusia cientos de personas marcharon en
apoyo a ese país se trata de salvar la
humanidad rusia defiende a la humanidad
la civilización y la iglesia ortodoxa es
una batalla del bien contra el mal y
sabemos gloria al señor que la madre a
rusia ganará
donde grupos de voluntarios se empacaba
en ayuda humanitaria destinado a ucrania
una madre compartió la carta de su hija
de 10 años en la que se declaraba muy
joven para ayudar pero dedicaba a sus
oraciones a las víctimas
la ong ambientalista greenpeace impidió
la entrada de un barco ruso al puerto de
hamburgo en la noche de este viernes los
manifestantes protestaban contra la
importación de carbón ruso en medio de
la guerra que vive ucrania unas 20
personas se acercaron al carguero grant
y cargado con unas 100.000 toneladas de
antracita y pintaron las palabras sin
carbón no hay guerra en el costado del
barco el producto no pudo ser descargado
el ataque ruso con misiles contra el
memorial a las víctimas del holocausto
en va a villar despertó las alertas
sobre los lugares históricos y
culturales que están en peligro en
ucrania país que alberga sitios a siete
sitios declarados como patrimonio
mundial de la unesco el siguiente
informe les contamos como los museos
trabajan para proteger sus colecciones
en medio de la guerra
no es sólo un lugar de arte en la ciudad
occidental del bifi los empleados del
museo de etnografía y artesanía ubicaron
paneles metálicos en las ventanas una
apuesta por proteger su colección que
incluye relojes joyas alfombras y piezas
culturales de toda europa
por supuesto no estaremos a salvo de un
misil pero esperamos estar a salvo de
las ondas de choque
queremos proteger al menos una parte de
los objetos porque tenemos una enorme
colección de arte que es admirada por
colegas y visitantes europeos
algunos museos han conseguido guardar
sus obras y sumarse a los esfuerzos para
ayudar en la guerra como el museo
nacional de arte donde se están
almacenando y distribuyendo suministros
de emergencia el centro histórico de la
ciudad es uno de los siete lugares de
ucrania declarados como patrimonio
cultural de la humanidad entre los que
corren peligro en la capital kiev se
encuentran los santuarios de ortodoxos
más sagrados del país la catedral de
santa sofía y el monasterio de las
cuevas de kiev el director del museo
nacional de historia de ucrania aprecio
su preocupación en una carta a sus
colegas suecos no hay ninguna garantía
de que el patrimonio cultural ucraniano
no sea saqueado y trasladado a los
museos rusos sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que kiev ocupa un lugar especial
en la interpretación que hace putin de
la historia de rusia y sus raíces
algunas obras de arte ya se han perdido
el ministerio de asuntos exteriores
ucraniano informó que las fuerzas rusas
quemaron un museo ni bank y destruyendo
25 obras de la difunta artista
folclórica varia primen 5
cambiamos de tema y vamos a francia
porque finalizó el plazo para la
inscripción de candidaturas a las
presidenciales galas solo un día después
del anuncio tardío de la aspiración del
presidente manuel ma con que generó
reacciones desde todo el espectro
político un anuncio de candidatura que
generó múltiples reacciones desde el
mundo político después de la carta a los
franceses difundida por emanuel mack con
los otros aspirantes a la presidencia no
tardaron en pronunciarse los mensajes de
los candidatos de ultraderecha marine
lepén de agrupación nacional y eriksen
de reconquista buscaron ser contundentes
qué es lo que tengo para responder a
esta carta que leí rápidamente que estoy
en desacuerdo con él con cada una de las
líneas y que voy a hacer todo para que
los próximos años no sean con él sino
conmigo por fin la oposición de las dos
francias de los dos proyectos podrá
desarrollarse ante los franceses los
otros candidatos se manifestaron
satisfechos de poder por fin debatir con
el actual presidente y aprovecharon para
lanzar críticas a sus cinco años de
mandato efe los hechos son innegables
y la política hecha durante los últimos
cinco años debilitó a francia
y el 10 y 24 de abril los franceses y
las francesas deben poder elegir entre
diferentes modelos de sociedad y si
continuamos como antes en el statu quo
con emanuel macro
la tardanza en su postulación también
fue juzgada por sus contrincantes
consenso yo creo que los franceses no se
dejan engañar por todo esto todo está
hecho para que no haya campaña en manuel
macrón está en campaña desde hace un mes
con su dinero o decenas de miles de
millones fueron votados con las ventanas
con falsas promesas como la vez pasada
para la net de fusiones con la dan ya
fue la lista definitiva de los
candidatos presidenciales será
oficializada el próximo lunes 7 de marzo
por el consejo constitucional un
tribunal de argentina condenó al ex
obispo gustavo óscar sánchez a cuatro
años y medio de cárcel por abusar
sexualmente de dos ex seminaristas pero
ante el desarrollo del juicio sancetta
considerado cercano al papá francisco
negó las acusaciones en su contra y dijo
haber tenido una sana y buena relación
con todos los seminaristas en principio
el pontífice había defendido las
afirmaciones de sánchez años
nueva york- dejará de exigir tanto el
uso de mascarillas en el sistema
educativo público como la prueba de
vacunación para acceder al interior de
restaurantes teatros y otros espacios
así lo anunció el alcalde de la ciudad
eric adams tras informar que los
contagios han bajado considerablemente
no obstante las instituciones tendrán
que seguir realizando evaluación diaria
de síntomas y distribución de kits de
pruebas los niños menores de 5 años que
no pueden ser vacunados tendrán que
seguir llevando obligatoriamente
mascarilla en entornos escolares
es todo por el momento en france 24 a
ustedes gracias por acompañarnos en esta
jornada informativa los invitamos a
visitar nuestra web france24 puntocom
para ampliar todas las noticias y
repetir este y otros programas feliz
noche para todos
[Música]